ernie johnson shaq kenny and charles
later tonight warriors and nuggets but
first the rockets and spurs in san
antonio
as houston turns the page on the james
harden era nine games into his ninth
season
wearing the rocket uniform four team
deal
players winding up all over the place
james harden in brooklyn
rockets getting victor oladipo and dante
exum
rhodium's caroux a bunch of picks
the cavs getting jared allen and taurean
prince from brooklyn karis levert the
former net
now goes to indiana before we start the
discussion
we go back a couple of nights james
harden's last night as a rocket
what he had to say and later what his
now
former teammates had to say about that
we're just not good enough um you know
we just we don't you know
obviously chemistry talent-wise just
everything and it was clear
um like i said these last few games um
they just you know from the beginning of
the game they were just aggressive
uh vet veteran team obviously a
championship team and
um you know one of the best teams that
we have in this league
um you know i love this city um i
literally
you know i've done everything that i can
um
you know i mean this situation is is
crazy you know it's something that
i don't think can be fixed so um
yeah thanks
my interest in playing with john wall to
be brutally honest
and uh with that being said um the
disrespect
started way before you know any
interview
just the approach to training camp uh
showing up the way he did the antics off
the court
i mean the disrespect started way before
so uh this isn't something that
you know all of a sudden happened you
know last night
that's completely unfair to the rest of
the guys in the locker room i've been on
those teams
and my 11 years been the league i've
been on team like in my first five years
where
it was all about me me me me not about
the team and that hurts
and it brings everybody down so when we
get all on the same page
we can be something good here and uh we
can't dwell down on it because it's only
been nine games like come on man
you want to jump off the cliff off of
nine games a lot of basketball still be
played
shaggy got a problem with how james
harden forced his way out of houston
uh yes i know one is the business of
basketball
but you know when you say you you gave
the city your all
that ain't true and i'm about to say
some things and keep in mind i have g14
classification to say these things uh
you asked for the white hour we gave
them to you
didn't work out you asked for chris paul
we gave them to you we asked what you
asked for some shooters
we gave it to you we asked for westbrook
your homeboy
from little league we gave them to you
didn't work out and when you say i gave
you everything
i say no you didn't because the last
five games when it comes to elimination
you're one in four you've been shooting
41 percent 24
from three uh 32 attempts
32 assists and 27 turnovers
i used to be like james i used to come
home and complain
man he didn't do anything and my father
recipe started to feel past you to say
but what the hell did you do
he ain't doing nothing he ain't step up
when when he was supposed to step up so
you know when you're the man and you
make all the money you make 30 40
million
it's a big responsibility chuck has says
this many times when you're the man
you got a big responsibility it's all on
you so when it comes time to show up
he ain't show up so i know a lot of
people in houston glad he's gone so now
he's
he got his little super team he got to
win this year if you don't win this year
it's a bus
period is it a given that uh with kyrie
kevin durant and james harden that they
were in the finals
hell no you go ahead kitty okay
i at first i i did not think you were
going to take that approach
jack that that surprised me it was not
it surprised me not shocking but it
surprised me i was like remember those
are real
i i didn't i i never thought of it that
way
until you said it and to i've honestly
never thought of it that way because
i've just looked at we're good you're
about to see one vp's right
yeah but listen when it comes time to
show up in that game i i
hey that's the game i want i i like to
hear it because i like i say i like to
hear things i
think about um nets
um what james brings to them is you know
they don't have to skill themselves
they're not as deep
but they they don't have to skill
themselves into winning every game
because
kevin durant is more skilled than most
players kyrie is
skilled than most players but at times
even when kevin is not on target
he's bigger he's more athletic
and he can get by just on his size
same with james when he's off he's still
big enough to say i could dominate you
from my my size so they have two guys
now kyrie is a skill guy he's going to
dominate you on his skill he's not
always more athletic and bigger
so at times you could possibly be there
so now the three of them
like chuck if you don't get to the east
um to the conference finals
i mean to the nba finals it is a bust
this is you got to work oh they're all
in yeah
obviously and you say it's it's not a
guarantee
i don't think it's even closer guarantee
ernie you got
the only one of those three guys who has
proven to me he's not selfish
and not a mean guy is it's k.d
kitty went to golden state and he
sacrificed
james hard and kyrie irving have never
shown me
like no i just want to win that's the
most important thing
you got one guy katie is he's unselfish
those two guys ain't proven to me they
just care about their numbers
and i don't think they're gonna make the
sacrifice they're gonna get less shots
are those two guys gonna say you know
what
i'm just gonna play hard and play
defense and not worry about my
individual numbers
and to me that's a hell no i don't think
these two guys don't think he did that
in oklahoma city though
you know he won james harden then all
right he wasn't he was he wasn't james
harden dan right i got you and
uh but the x factor to this whole thing
right now is kyrie irving
well and he did that to my part see this
is what i think happened this is just
main thing
i think they are sick of kyrie already
and says we better make this james hard
trade
because we cannot count on kyrie that's
just me talking
he a wild card is an understatement
ernie kyrie has not proven he could be
trusted
as a leader he can trust it as a guy who
can be part of a championship team
but when he was asked to be a leader in
cleveland before lebron there
we could say that was a failure when he
was asked to be a leader in boston
we can say that could be a failure and
when he went to brooklyn last year
remember
after early seasons like we ain't got no
players here
so when you listen ernie when you are
the man
it's night and day you can be all these
robins
you can be i'll tell you what shows the
most and ken is checking
every coach in football or baseball i
know about baseball
in baseball excuse me in basketball and
football every coach ain't a head coach
and every guy cannot deal with the
pressure of being the man
like what some of the things that was
said about me
hey listen it hurts my feeling back in
the day don't anymore
but like i say it's a responsibility and
james and kyrie have not proven to me
and they don't have to appear with me
not to prove to the basketball world
if they have the three and again we
don't know when we'll see
kyrie irving on the floor again in that
next uniform but if they have the three
do they go all the way one word comes to
mind
and it's sacrifice and you have to want
to sacrifice
i could have took every shot ernie but
no i got to sacrifice i got to keep
everybody involved i heard kenny and
charles said they got it from the great
john wooden
true definition of great players getting
everybody else involved james could
dribble all day but you gotta you
gotta get mr harris going because you're
gonna need him when you get doubled so
you have to sacrifice so now we're gonna
get back to whose team
is it i'm gonna tell you it's kd's team
uh uh you know james harden aren't used
to that kyrie you said well you know
kyrie is used to a little bit but now
that james is there
like charles said shots are going to
lessen and are they going to suck not
only shots are going to listen
is different when those reporters and
this is what is an understatement guys
don't admit
whenever those reporters go by your
locker
and they go to his first then they come
to you oh yeah like
that for guys who have been that guy
yeah they say
oh that doesn't yeah i've been in there
too though it could bother you guys we
got to see if it does
it's going to be a fun fascination i
mean kd went from the splash brothers to
the dribble brothers
[Laughter]
and rockets coming up from san antone
back with more in a second